we do have in the studio with us that
the Chief Inspector of Prisons who took
a look at manston Charlie Taylor Charlie
great to have you this morning
um let's just start with the with the
the basic facts here what did you
discover uh through your visits to the
manston center is it in your view and I
put this question to Robert General is
it in your review fit for purpose well
we visited originally in the summer and
though we had a number of criticisms
that we made of of the center actually
it was generally functioning reasonably
well as was Western jet foil at Dover
where migrants arrive off the boats I
then returned in September to have
another look and already we were
beginning to see some of those risks
that we flagged up in the summer
manifest themselves so people were
starting to spend longer on site people
were unable to make contact with family
people were staying in accommodation
that wasn't good enough what we're now
hearing is is that things have become
much worse that people are spending much
longer periods of time at the center and
uh and and that I've announced that we
will go back and reinspect in the near
future when you say that the
accommodation is unacceptable just just
to explain exactly what you mean by this
I mean ultimately this is a site at
which people are supposed to be spending
no longer than 24 48 hours that's right
it's a short-term holding facility and
that means people should come in they
should be quickly processed and they
should move on to suitable accommodation
what's happening at Manson when I
visited was people were sleeping on the
floors on on their rubber mats down on
the floors and then very thin blankets
or mattresses lots and lots of people in
a room
um all squished in together very
uncomfortable the the the room for
families has lots and lots of different
families all sharing the same room uh
very young children older children uh
and some and for a few hours that would
be acceptable but where people are
spending long periods of time there it
just isn't what about the health
concerns that there are on site we've
had reports of cases of Scabies of
diphtheria of MRSA I mean all of that is
it must be troubling to you as well well
it's inevitable if if you put people
together in very close proximity for
long periods of time particularly people
who've come from parts of the world
where perhaps they haven't had the
opportunity to have vaccines uh
unfortunately the risk is that things
like scabies or diphtheria will appear
personally in your position and I know
this because my grandfather actually
worked in the inspector for Education
you have to choose your language very
very carefully when you tell the home
office that they need to get a grip on
this situation that sounds to me like
the strongest criticism that someone in
your position can possibly make
we'll be back we'll be back at the
center we'll be looking to see an
improvement in in treatment and
conditions of the detainees who are
there and yes they need to get a grip is
this situation solvable is it fixable
and if so home I think it is fixable
um providing suitable accommodation for
people uh making sure that the processes
that happen in manston are efficient
that they're streamlined that there are
enough staff enabled in order to do that
now there are many complications it's a
difficult site to run but we've seen it
operating pretty well when we were there
in the summer so this is doable but for
whatever reason things seem to have
unraveled more recently just just in
terms of of the day job and you go
you're in and out of Prisons up and down
this country comparing manston to to you
know your average prison the idea that
someone can't use the toilet without
having the door open the idea that
people are not being having access to to
Fresh Air I mean it strikes me that
those are things that would be
unacceptable and rarely to be found in
the prison system I would be horrified
if I went into a prison where prisoners
didn't have mattresses where prisoners
didn't have flushing lavatories where
prisoners didn't have uh telephones that
they could stay in touch with family and
friends those are three things that we
see at Manson similarly if they couldn't
get out into the fresh air and of course
one thing that you don't find in well in
in mainstream prisons you find in young
offenders institutions young people just
a just a word from you on the way in
which they're being treated we had
anecdotally you know one child had been
detained there for for longer than 40
well for 48 hours other children are as
you mentioned sleeping on the mat I mean
that in and of itself should be enough
to prompt a government into action it's
extremely concerning that children are
being asked to sleep on the floor in a
combination that's that's wholly wholly
unsuitable and bear in mind that some of
these people have had incredibly long
Journeys some of them are potentially
victims of torture victims of all sorts
of abuse and also potentially victims of
trafficking as well and the idea that we
then expect them to sleep on the floor
for long periods of time just is not
acceptable so what happens next from
your position what is the time scale
that the home office has to get this
sorted out and if it doesn't and you
mentioned you're going back into to see
what happens and if it doesn't improve
what is the following step well we we
will we will return to the site we we
won't announce when that will be we'll
return to the site we will expect to see
substantial changes in in what's
happening there we'll expect to see
migrants moving on more quickly to
suitable accommodation and that many of
the things that we've flagged up in this
report in terms of uh seeking out people
with vulnerabilities making sure the
victims of torture are identified making
sure translation services are in place
we'll be going back and we're looking
for those things if we don't see an
improvement there we'll we will raise
our future concerns Charlie honest
question I mean have you seen anything
like it before
it's a it's a real worry now we were
there earlier in the year when things
were not so bad indeed so we haven't
been back to inspect recently we will go
back and see but what we're hearing from
a number of very credible sources so
Roger Gale
um from Dave Neal from the inspector of
the boys from trade unions who are
working there but things are going wrong
at Manson and as I said before the home
office I need to get a grip Charlie said
a great time in the studio this morning
really appreciate it